l'équipe de l'eeie a d'ailleurs passé
par la ville puisque d'après les
informations qu'on a pu avoir ne s'est
pas arrêté là ville de zaporizhya faut
rappeler que la ville de zaporijia se re
se trouve en réalité en amont sur l'eau
n'y a pas que vous voyez des rémois qui
est donc cette rivière est un petit peu
un aval pardon de la ville deux apports
hijja et à une soixante une soixantaine
de kilomètres à vol d'oiseau de
l'endroit où je me trouve c'est à dire
la ville de happo riediens cette
centrale se trouve en réalité à la vie
des nerfs radars et selon les médias
russes est bien l'équipe de leioa serait
arrivé havas il kiffe qui est le point
de passage entre la zone contrôlée par
l'ukraine et les zones occupées par la
russie et d'après ces mêmes médias
russes est bien l'équipe de l'aiea
serait arrêtée et donc les russes
auraient fait le choix de ne pas
forcément faciliter leur passage donc
nous allons voir combien de temps
l'équipe de l' ua mais a passé ce check
point était ensuite se dirigera vers
cette centrale des nerfs retard pour
l'instant très peu d'informations sur le
calendrier de cette visite ce qu'on a vu
aussi c'est que les russes de leur côté
appelle à une visite d'une seule journée
une journée d'inspection et puis
d'ailleurs s'en irait les ukrainiens de
leur côté et l'onu à eux demandent
plusieurs journées d'inspection donc une
inspection complète l'eeie a même pas ta
voix de son secrétaire général raffaele
grossier appel est ce qui est une
mission permanente dans cette centrale
pour s'assurer et bien qu'elle qu'il n'y
ait pas d'incident nucléaire durant
cette guerre l'onu qui appelle également
avec les états unis est ce que la zone
soit démilitarisé mais pour l'instant la
russie ignore ces appels donc cette
équipe va bientôt arriver dans la
centrale on ne sais pas dans combien de
temps ni quelles seront les modalités
mais là son beau travail sera de
surveiller l'intégrité de l'intégrité de
la structure de la centrale t'assurer
qu'il n'y a pas de fuite également
s'assurer du bon fonctionnement des
mécanismes de sécurité de la centrale et
puis voir dans quelles conditions
travaillent le millier d'ingénieurs
ukrainiens qui sont toujours sur le site
qui font fonctionner cette centrale qui
est désormais sous contrôle militaire
russe